storage based on Delta Lake to
save
process data different features then
there is a that ml said send boxes that
were based on data breaks the outputs
like Python scripts and Docker files and
whatever is needed to whatever artifacts
are needed to
solve this
this flow of War
[Music]
submitted in the CI process in natural
devops and then integrated with
basically runtime for either real-time
serving of or by disturbing and
experiments for attracting ml flow and
models will also stored in ml flow as a
model registry
um
so what would like the typical
limitations of that the steam buffer is
in so at a high level uh there are more
uh basically pros and cons of of these
Solutions of this approach uh actually
uh like the the biggest advantages were
that
um
these approach actually provided High
flexibility in the sense that each team
used to build whatever they want support
their own like features from the
platform perspective uh there are more
very limited dependencies across the
team they used to build it pretty much
independently uh and it was relatively
easier to
like manage it from organizational
standpoint because all all domains were
pretty much independent but there were a
number of disadvantages as we talked in
the beginning uh predominantly related
to limited functionality and high cost
of ownership
across this platforms and there were
like a number of me a number of typical
technology gaps in each of these
solutions for example from data
management perspective typically they
did not have any tools for data quality
control for data governance
um uh also like most of the teams they
tend to create very large processing
graphs and uh with like many different
data engineering and model training
steps which was also very challenging to
manage from the infrastructure
perspective uh they of course lacked of
like infrastructure as a court
automation
some steps were
like implemented and semi-monal way from
the production server and perspective
again in many cases they just in these
teams they just used to build some
artifacts and deploy them in production
and say the semi-manual mode with some
manual tests configuring monitoring in
my own way and of course functionality
from develops perspective was typically
Limited in the sense that they in many
cases did not have proper experiments
tracking
no feature stores no a b testing
Frameworks and so on
and in this situation basically um
um a bearable like free approach three
strategies that will consider it as a
potential uh next step forward so
basically what we just discussed I would
call it like decentralized approach
meaning that there are like multiple
different teams the teacher which has
specific uh goals that they pursuing and
they are free to use whatever technology
tools to for achieving these goals and
you know this way they typically can be
very motivated because they have no
external dependencies they completely
own the solution that they develop the
second approach is to build a
centralized platform
ml platform that serves all the teams
and serves all the needs and
basically it enables
different domain teams to onboard the
use cases develop their use cases having
very limited knowledge and almost no
develops devops resources but
development of such a platform it's like
in some cases it's a good idea but in
many cases it um like represent a lot of
challenges for example if you think
about this particular
this particular case they have like 30
different teams and uh each of these
teams was a kind of unique in terms of
how they uh what kind of use cases they
built and how they approach them and
basically building a platform that would
cover all these all these
um all these needs all the required
capabilities would be a very time
consuming very uh very challenging
but the third approach that was
considered here was actually something
in between of these two extremes that
was built in the mailbox center of
excellence basically the idea was that
it will be one centralized team for
creation of essentially like templates
and reusable artifacts that can be then
customized for each specific team and
then it will be like a standardized
process for creating basically instances
of ml platforms for these different
teams based on this centrally managed
templates and but at the same time these
platforms could be customized for the
needs of each individual team so that on
the one hand we would have many
different like each team will have its
own platform in a sense but the
platforms will be created according to
best practices and standards that will
be centrally managed by a team that
specializes in in basically building ml
platforms according to best practices
so um from the technical perspective how
it was implemented how the solution was
envisioned so basically a division was
that
[Music]
the Coe team cloud of Excellence team
will create standard templates that
typically like we will basically two
sets of artifacts first set of artifacts
are related to like infrastructure as a
code scripts for the platform itself and
then templates for different types of
Applied projects like projects for base
processing stream processing real-time
serving and so on and then for each
particular domain team or for each
particular project they will
basically
take these templates do customizations
according to the needs of individual
teams create
workspaces or environments
and then the domain team will use this
repositories in particular this project
repositories to create pipelines or
whatever artifacts they need to create
and then
the artifacts will be deployed in
production using the capabilities of
this platform created out of out of the
template
and also it's important that this the
solution was envisioned as a multi-cloud
solution so at least like uh for
beginning Now location and gcp was uh
was supported
so um basically there was a need to
provide this like this flexibility as
well as well as ability to customize the
capabilities of the platform for
individual teams
so uh in this uh in this approach of
course uh like one of the central
questions is how exactly these templates
are managed because it's uh it's not a
trivial process of how
uh how to organize this so that the
platforms can actually be updated and uh
at a high level uh the workflow was
essentially as follows
basically
the workflow that was implemented is
that it starts with the data science
team like the main team that needs to
create an instance of a platform for a
specific uh for a specific need or
specific use case and they specify they
select one of the project types they
select ml services that need to be
provided by the platform and then they
essentially create like a service
request for a cue team and then the Coe
team they take a property template and
create a repository that contains all
like infrastructure as a quarter
artifacts for uh
for this new project and then for new
projects they basically do
customizations of
of these templates to meet needs of a
specific team then they essentially
recreate the environments essentially
performing like terraform apply and then
they create a repository for
for the actual projects repository there
are the actual uh like
data engineering scripts or data
engineering jobs or model 3 and model
serving scripts will
I believe and it also can be an update
of an existing project so that
in some cases this data science teams
they can create requests to customize or
update or improve the existing the
existing project and in that case it is
again handled by the Coe team so that
they do customization of of the existing
project of the existing template and
then basically recreate the environment
so in this like later case how these
updates are handled uh also like another
important aspect of it is that
uh basically the goal was to reduce the
load on the Coe team so that they do not
handle all uh all possible requests all
possible updates that needs to be done
in the company and um to enable that the
approach was to basically create like
several different types of several
different like tiers of updates and so
that some updates can be handled by uh
essentially like data science teams data
scientists themselves some updates can
be handled by devops Engineers so
mailbox engineers in each individual
team and some updates can be handled by
the Coe team so from that perspective
typically how it worked
updates in the like
modeling logic updates and
configurations we usually handled by
like data scientists themselves and they
were provided with tools for making
these updates and then deploying these
updates to production
the updates that are required to
change the environment itself for
example types of instances the amount of
resources for production serving and so
on will handle typically by
mlops engineers at the Domain level and
more more complex updates work
usually required to involve the Coe team
to handle and in this later case
typically the approach was that
the main teams they like in most cases
the main teams they used to create
requests themselves so that the in
general level Familiar of course with
how this platforms uh like instant read
and familiar with
the deployment automation they used to
create
uh uh the requests themselves then this
uh essentially pull requests go used to
go to the cue team they used to make
they used to review these updates make
changes if needed merge the spool
requests and then apply uh updates to
the actual environment so this way it
was
basically a collaboration between the
domain teams and Coe teams and in a
productive way so that the workload on
the Coe teams was relatively Limited
so um
now let me talk about the migration
strategy how like the whole program was
structured because it is
it also has like certain implications on
the design of the solution
so basically uh the uh the entire
program was structured in the way that
basically the goal was to enable uh like
step-by-step migration and also
migration uh in in such a way that
multiple uh this like 30 different teams
can perform this migration in parallel
so that
um the entire migration time frame is is
reasonable
and from that perspective
basically the process started with
creation of this common templates that
we just talked about and after that for
most teams uh virtual migration started
with migration of this of the servant
layer which is shown in green here
because uh like in most cases at least
in this uh like in this particular case
serving layers were relatively
lightweight they pretty much were like
deployments of
runtimes for like real-time scoring and
it was relatively easy to uh to migrate
them as a separate step and at the same
time data engineering processes model
training processes were
remained
remain basically on the on the Legacy
platform but then
The Next Step was to onboard the basic
data sets to the newly instantiated
platforms uh migrate data engineering
processes than migrate design and like
Implement new ml pipelines for modeling
training and
base inference and then reloaded to
production and then typically this was
like iterative process for upscaling to
like new markets and so on after that
so to illustrate that this is an example
of how this like intermediate State
looked like for um
for one of the projects so basically
this is the state that uh like on the on
the left hand side there is like a
essentially a legacy solution
for in this particular case for
producing
essentially demand forecast based on
like historical sales data and so on
like typical typical scenario and then
on the right hand side there is like a
new solvent layer that in this
particular case was implemented in gcp
so basically it used to ingest this like
forecasted values that were produced in
like in the batch mode on a regular
basis and then there was like
transactional storage for Serbian this
solving this data to
like applications that needed to query
these applications in real time there
was a H the corresponding so a
corresponding service and a number of
endpoints to which Legacy applications
were connected and um also in this
particular case the flow for uh Serbian
like asynchronous requests for doing
some uh like
um
stock optimization computations and
basically like this right hand side part
was like migrated first and it was
replaced it replaced the Legacy
application and transparent way that did
not require to modify this this Legacy
applications
um so um
now let's uh let's go a little bit
deeper into what like what specifically
was in these different templates because
we talked about this process of like
template management and how we do
migration but we did not talk uh I did
not talk a lot about uh what
specifically uh what was inside of these
templates and what kind of basically
capability standard capabilities were
implemented so um in one of the previous
slide we talked about
the limitations that most of the teams
had across these different categories
such as data management infrastructure
management production serving and
basically the goal of the Coe team was
to create standard templates that used
to address these uh these limitations
for example for from the data management
standpoint the goal was to enable
basically more like data mesh type of
type of a solution so that different
teams can produce data products and
there are standard services for
data observability for controlling the
quality of the produced data products
and so on of course from infrastructure
management and cicgam standpoint the
goal was to improve the level of
automation
um and uh also was a goal to introduce
like most specialized services for
example feature stores for uh real-time
scenarios experiment tracking tools
and so on
so um how it was implemented
um
let's start with uh with the data layer
so this is uh like a simplified someone
simplified example of how the data layer
was implemented in these templates so
basically like it included actually like
four different parts the first part was
uh
basically the development environment so
it included
processes for like services for data
engineering and data governance in this
particular case it was implemented on
the on the databricks stack and
basically the outputs of these
the outputs of these processes were
um
data like for example engineered
features that can be used to for model
inference purposes and
uh these this prepared data were used in
the development environment uh there are
the actual models work like deployed in
the stage and what I will talk about how
exactly it used to happen in the in the
next slide then the second part of
course was the production environment so
in the production environment uh
um basically the feature store was used
for accessing different features using
Point requests like in real time and
there was a separate process basically
for replicating
data from this offline storage to this
uh to this feature store as a part of
the data management standard data
management template then from the
runtime data were sent to
collected data for example interaction
data feedback data used to send into
data streams and data was
a separate like real-time feature
engineering pipeline that used to
consume this data and apply like the
same data preparation data
transformation processes to produce or
update the features that can be used to
catch up with ongoing data and the data
quality was controlled using Apache soda
framework and the data once then
eventually landed into this into the
storage and finally the fourth component
was a continuous learning pipeline so
that data uh that this uh like
continuously updated data were used to
retrain
um models that were deployed in
production
so um
then from uh the um
uh cicd perspective which is a
counterpart of the previous slide uh we
also had the development environment
there are
in this environment uh basically like
the actual uh
uh uh model training scripts were
created and then
it was integrated with CI processes that
used to basically create like final
artifacts provision environment for a
model
like model retraining model testing and
then uh models were packages that can
deploy it in the demo flow and then from
ml flow we had deployments of course in
the development environment as well as
in production environment there are also
for some additional components related
to observability and model monitoring
um
and finally The Continuous learning
pipeline it was like basically an
instance of this model training pipeline
that you used to on a scheduled basis or
on real time to catch up with latest
data updates and then the produced
produced new model versions that were
deployed into the registry and then to
uh to production environment so this is
basically this I hope gives some some
idea of how
like the actual uh the actual Services
uh were implemented and what basically
most teams got out of this uh out of
this migration and out of these
templates
and there were some additional Services
I will skip it for the sake of time for
example Services related to
experimentation experiment management
which is actually a very complex topic
by itself
but finally I just want to mention that
this like template based approach it can
be this is actually just one possible
application of these templates
we can we can use the strategy to create
this Cloud center of excellence and
instantiate many different models for um
different teams but actually the same
technique can be used for solving quite
different problems one typical example
is building
basically scaling the processes by
markets for example if you have many
different markets globally and you have
some process that show some model that
uh it's the world like initially
developed for one of the markets then
um basically uh what can be done this uh
the solution can be templatized so that
um like typical steps implemented in
this solution like fishing engineering
model stem cells business Logic on top
of it validation criteria and so on can
be uh basically packaged as a genetic
template and then instantiated for for
more markets
um
yep so that's uh that's pretty much it
uh just to summarize uh in this talk we
uh we spoke about uh
basically how to identify right problem
to solve as we just talked it can be a
scalability problem in terms of a number
of teams but it can also be some other
type of problems like managing multiple
markets then usually it's a good idea to
consider different approaches for
building uh the platform we talked about
the decentralized centralized and Coe
approach
then we talked about how to design
actual data Ops and envelops services
and processes how to structure the
Migration by phases and then how like
the future they can go in scaling across
different markets or development of new
additional Services can be can be
structured
yep so that's uh that's it thank you
[Applause]
we have five minutes for questions
hi Elia great talk and I like that it
highlights the complexity of this kind
of projects
um did you have um kpis that the
business had us of the performance of
the teams like before and after the
migration so sometimes like you need to
have these metrics that you track like
time to deployment or or others like
what what was the rationale behind this
yep so uh there are more like a number
of I would not say kpis but terrible
like a number of like specific targets
that they will go into solve like one of
them was actually
basically simple onboarding process for
example and obviously uh you know even
if you do not Define a kpi for it it's
quite obvious that this approach like on
board and it can be done in a matter of
days as opposed to you know like uh
weeks or months with this decentralized
approach
um Japan the second the second target
actually in this uh like in this
particular case was uh like
harmonization of the skill sets because
if you have like this many different
teams uh that uh like solve their
problems in different ways using
different technology Stacks then uh it's
uh it's difficult from like Resource
Management perspective how you hire
people how you move people around across
different teams and this approach and
basically it obviously provided like
improvements from uh from that
perspective
uh I had a question about the terraform
templates did those already exist at the
company where you were performing this
transformation or if not like how much
time was allocated to building those
tabletized infrastructure models
yep thank you
um so uh in this like in this case study
the state of form skips they did not
exist but uh this skips were created
based on the sdks that are typically
provided by Cloud vendors for example
like Google they provide SDK
specifically for like terraform SDK
specifically for their services and so
on so basically like most of the work
here was essentially about taking this
like sdks doing some extensions for like
you know like non-standard things or
some things that were like missed by
some reason in this sdks and then
like combining all the things together
so that this templates can be like
actually it's not treated in a
particular company
hey um really good talk thank you
um so you mentioned about migrating
migrating sorry
migrating the platform and starting to
deliver a value from it
um so it's kind of interested in
you mentioned you started with the model
inference because it's relatively
lightweight and easier to start with
how did you start to deliver a value
from things like a feature and the
terraform templates which only start to
deliver value once other things can can
use them if that makes sense
um
so just let me make sure I understand
the question so basically
um the question is about
alien like adding more services and how
to get really out of it
so what your migration strategy was so
that you made sure you could demonstrate
that you were adding value from these
more complex pieces such as the feed
store
um
well um
well actually like migration strategy it
was a little bit like more sophisticated
than I just shown because there were
some additional goals for example
um uh there was a goal to redesign the
data engineering flows as I mentioned in
one of the slides basically there were a
lot of like issues and challenges
related to like complex Legacy processes
uh that were difficult to maintain and
so on so as this migration was
implemented like one of the for example
like one of the benefits that was gained
through it is that these processes were
redesigned that was not just like lift
and shift migration and uh this way
there were simplifications like in terms
of like management and maintenance of
these flows for example uh
uh because we start with migration of
this solvent layer we kind of separating
it out then we uh basically redesign
let's say uh data integration data and
boarding processes uh it's like you can
view it as a separate benefit right that
it's now like a separate process that
can be managed separately and it also
can be optimized in terms of resource
usage in terms of slas and so on then
you move uh model training let's say
processes or model inference processes
and this way basically in um
to answer your question basically in
each of these steps you can you can
demonstrate the benefit and terms of
like at least from operational
standpoint as well as from uh like
functional improvements because in like
in many cases like actual
um for example models were improved and
their performance in terms of like
business outcomes like conversion rates
or forecast and accuracies or whatever
it is or also improved question
that's all the time we have for
questions but please join me in giving a
round of applause for Ilya
thank you